well move over billy hargrove good
afternoon ladies afternoon billy yeah
because noah schnapp is making sure no
one's running by the pool
oh my god this is such a weird feeling
you and us both noah check out the
stranger things star having a blast with
his fellow lifeguards
[Music]
in another post noah's whistle is
literally bouncing to the beat
[Music]
[Music]
well we definitely applaud a side hustle
thank you that's nice of you it's a
curious move considering noah stars on
one of the most popular tv shows ever
but in a recent interview for flaunt
magazine noah reveals the part-time gig
is all about staying humble quote it's a
kind of uh just for fun thing i've kind
of grown up with a normal life and
normal friends and stuff outside of
stranger things so it's kind of kept me
grounded we could just play d and d and
nintendo for the rest of our lives okay
will's plan sounds pretty nice but his
real-life counterpart is thinking about
his future noah is heading to the
university of pennsylvania this fall he
even shared the moment he and his family
found out about his acceptance
[Music]
but until my moment comes
[Music]
details are few and far between about
the fifth and final season of stranger
things with the twitter account for the
writers room only offering a teasy
behind-the-scenes pick it's very cool
just for me as the actor to play in this
new environment whether it's in the
lifeguard chair or on the set this past
season noah appreciates any change of
scenery this season is for us we're
fighting with guns and
and words and and things that aren't
like what i'm used to in the upside down
with the slime and this and the spores
and everything so it was just really fun
to try that new side of things and it
was just very realistic and
crazy
[Music]